bienvenue sur la face cachée de la lune
messieurs logiquement vaut pas mieux
être au sommet de la montagne pour
gagner notre job c'est de séparer les
talibans et les gens ordinaires
comment on peut remplir notre mission si
on n'est pas en sécurité
c'est leur respect qui nous protège j'ai
changé ça pour rien au monde on est
comme des frères ici tu pries pour moi
d'accord évidemment que je suis plus je
t'aime plus que tout c'est qu'en passant
par leur coeur et leur raison qu'on
pourra gagner sauf qu'en face c'est nos
tripes et notre sens qu'ils attendent
désolé mon pote mais c'est comme ça que
ça se passe ici à chaque fois qu'ils
nous attaquent ils testent nos réactions
s'ils lancent une offensive on sera
piégé les talibans arrivent ils sont
partout ils avis
et pas mais vous c'est du sérieux cette
fois les dents quand je reste en arrière
pour vous couvrir
on va reprendre la pompe est
on n'a aucun support aérien ou le
moindre renfort nous sommes sont bloqués
là-bas notre dépôt de munitions et à
seulement 35 m et là il ya tout ce qu'il
faut pour qu'on continue à se battre
laissez-moi les idées c coupé
vous croyez qu'ils aiment bouffer du 20
mm
ça va aller mettez pas autour de moi tu
vas pas mourir non se retient
section rouge
[Musique]
on va reprendre la bastille